The joe rogan experience.
I was listening to this thing.
It was a talk once that this guy was giving about,
um,
uh,
all sorts of different psychological disorders in one of them was a theory that
they had had at one point in time about schizophrenia,
schizophrenia being,
um,
having something to do with smells and that
will,
that you give off certain that it's a form for mono will issue that you give off
a certain smell and then people respond to that smell and they go,
oh,
this guy's weird.
And then you go,
wow,
I'm fucking weird.
And then it starts this chain reaction that makes you weird,
that makes you yourself pheromones upset someone else.
Yeah.
Because your,
your reality becomes defined by people avoiding you and freaking out by you and
you can get kind of crazy because of the successive right.
People even more secure in who they are.
Whoa,
look at you fucking take that.
Hey,
we all,
we all start from different places.
Allows us,
last year some people had shitty homes without organized parents like you.
I,
fair enough.
I think the schizophrenia,
I think the pheromone thing is huge.
I have dated,
I did remember dating someone.
We didn't really have anything in common,
but we couldn't stop smelling each other well,
went to a bar and I just buried my face in his neck and I just like,
I can't stop.
There was something,
some people just smell like home for some reason.
Not necessarily your home,
but like you get a very comfortable feeling.
He's turned out to be,
you know,
a nightmare.
But the,
on a pheromone level,
it was so,
he was a nightmare.
Nightmare psychologically.
I mean it was,
we just didn't work out and that's fine,
but I remember just sitting there and I was just like,
I cannot stop doing this.
Was He the nightmare where you uh,
we'll talk about off the air.
It was definitely,
it's definitely not me.
I don't want to say what it was because I wasn't listening to happens to know
and we'll be like,
I know that was right.
Right,
right.
I will share with you a story if you want to please,
please.
Because this is failing everything.
And I share this for the first time in Tampa this weekend and I hadn't told the
scoot on up to the microphone,
let us know.
Um,
I,
this is just a quick not wearing headphones.
That's why I'm letting people know,
like when you move away,
left and to the right of these things,
it changes the volume.
Do you think it really matters if you put it left to right?
Like,
no,
that doesn't matter.
But if we look looking for blanche,
I was looking for the volume.
It's up here.
Oh,
that's fine.
Next to the salt.
That is a salt rock.
We're hippies here.
We have,
um,
look,
I have a lava lamps.
Salt rocks.
Yeah.
Jimi Hendrix.
I couldn't eat looking at the Predator thing,
like if I had a sandwich or won't be able to look at that and eat,
it grosses me out.
It's just a mask.
Halloween costumes gross me out with the smell of latex and that's actually
hard.
That's like a,
a model that was made by special effects guy was looking at,
cause he's so scary,
but like that thing couldn't eat you.
Uh,
you short could,
it would rip you apart.
It's small now.
Yeah.
But it would chew chunks of you.
Let's,
and those other things act as teeth to just pulls hunks of meat off you.
But it depends on how it can articulate it.
Just trying to make them human.
I think he would appreciate that.
Okay.
So here's my story please.
Cause we were talking about relationship at the beginning.
So I went through a breakup like a month and a half ago,
maybe two months ago.
I feel like you'll have you of all people were appreciate the story and I'll
give you the abridged version.
Um,
me,
the juicy details.
So basically I met this guy a year,
two years,
not this thanksgiving,
the last one on the plane.
And we hit it off and he told me his name and he said he went to Yale and he
worked in,
we'll say,
well,
he worked in finances,
we'll just leave it at that.
And so I knew him for a year,
never wanted to date him.
And eventually we dated,
we dated for for three months.
And during the time we were dating,
um,
before we'd started dating,
he told me he bought a house and I never wanted to see the house because I
whatever,
it wasn't dating him,
I didn't care.
So we start dating and the whole time we're dating,
things start getting weird.
Like we get along perfectly,
but there are certain aspects of his personal life that are like not checking
out.
Like I told my mom,
I was like,
Oh hey,
this is his name and this is where he works.
So she googled him because that's what moms do.
And his work bio says that he graduated from,
uh,
from a different college,
not he's anyone to Yale is that he'd graduates around.
So I call him,
I'm like,
why does it say that?
He's like,
Oh my God,
they've cut and pasted the wrong bio.
It's a mess up.
My company's a mess.
I'm like,
okay,
I get wrong.
Bio's all the time.
Like I totally get it.
And I was like,
I want to send you a present.
What's your address?
He was like,
oh,
just send it to my work.
And I was like,
no,
I want to send it to your house.
So he gives me this address.
So I sent him a gift and he gets it.
And then one day I'm out with my friend Laura,
we're at lunch and we start to build a case about why we think this guy is a
liar as a joke at first cause nothing's checking out.
So Laura's like,
let's drive by his house.
And I remember what the house looked like from the picture he'd sent me,
cause like six months before we were dating,
he was like,
check out this house that I bought.
So we go to the house and it's not a house,
it's an apartment.
And Laura goes up to the door and she's like looking in and all of a sudden the
girl opens the door and I'm just,
I'm just,
I was paralyzed and the girl looks at me,
she goes,
she was like,
hi,
can I help you guys?
And we're like,
oh,
we're just looking for the guy we're looking for.
And she was like,
Oh,
you're Eliza.
And I was like,
fuck,
do you know who I am?
And she was like,
Oh,
I'm his roommate.
And I was like,
okay,
well that's fine.
Like I'm just not a cheating thing.
But I was like,
so I call him and I'm like,
why do you have a roommate?
And he goes,
well,
um,
my mom is sick and she moved to La and she lives at my house and I,
I,
she lives there and I live with my friend to give my mom privacy.
And I was like,
all right,
well that's weird.
But like I still want to know where you live.
Oh God,
this guy should just change his number and run away from you.
Oh,
it gets better.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So it was like,
all right,
so I let it go and when we're together,
everything's great.
Like,
perfect.
You're not thinking about it at all.
Well that part I was like,
okay,
his mom has cancer.
That's when he told me,
and he's like,
she's wants privacy.
So I'm like,
okay.
And I fell in love with him in the first place because he told me she had cancer
and I got,
I wanted to take care of him.
And like that really like tugged on my heartstrings.
So I was like,
okay.
I met them on once and every single time after I met her once,
like the first week we started dating and every time after that I'd be like,
let me take,
if you're at work,
I'm like,
I've got free time.
Let me take your mom to lunch.
Let me take your mom to the movies.
Can we go to like anything?
Could never make it happen.
Let's go to brunch with your mom.
Let me do something.
Let me take her somewhere.
No one you met the mom.
Did her illness ever come up in conversation?
Because I thought that would be tactless for me to be like,
how's your cancer if she brought it up,
she brought her up.
No,
nothing.
They came with me to the craft store.
I had to buy stuff for Christmas party.
Um,
we didn't say much,
but I never,
so weeks are going by and I'm like,
I just want to hang out.
Like if you love me.
And he always talked about getting married,
stuff like that.
I'm like,
I should probably meet this woman more than once.
So he gives me,
so I go to that.
So it's not,
it's I call him and he's like,
uh,
my mom is living alone.
I intend to give her privacy.
And I was like,
okay,
that's fine,
but you need to tell me where you live.
You gave me that and I was like,
why are you being weird?
You gave me the address like six months ago before we were dating.
And he was like,
um,
I,
uh,
he is your guy.
He's like,
I just,
I,
my mom's asked for privacy.
I'm just trying to give that to her.
He kept saying that,
so I'm like,
all right.
So finally,
eventually he goes,
here's the address and he gives me,
this address is five to five Kilkia.
So I'm like,
all right,
that's not the real addresses.
So I have this address.
I'm like,
okay.
Thinking,
wow,
that took a lot for you to give.
That to me,
like this is clearly like an issue in everyone's got their boundaries,
everyone's got their baggage,
and I was trying to be respectful of that.
A couple of weeks go by,
my mom calls the yells registered,
you know,
registrar's office because it's such a me out,
no record of this guy ever graduating.
Oh your mom's awesome as everybody says.
So I call him and I'm like,
and I'm trying to be cool about it because again,
like this is someone that I love and we traveled together and you don't want to
push it.
And he's like,
I don't know.
I was only on campus for this amount of time,
did it.
Ah,
he'd already invited me to go to England with him for a skull and bones reunion,
like a whole thing.
And we,
it got cancelled because his mom had cancer.
So like,
I'm like letting all this go.
So he goes out of town,
I go to five to five cookies,
it doesn't exist.
So I call him and I'm like,
what are you fucking doing?
And he goes and he launching a store.
He goes,
when I lived in the city he lived in before he goes,
I had this crazy ex girlfriend,
everyone's got a crazy ex.
He was like,
and basically she wreak havoc on my social life and my personal life with my
family and I'm just very protective of that.
And my mom's sick and I'm just trying to like keep her out of that.
So I was like,
okay.
And I was like,
you need to give me your address.
This is the last time I'm going to ask you for this.
And I'm trying not to like push something.
So he comes over,
he gives me the address,
his mom's number and his email.
He's like,
I'm an open book,
whatever you want to know.
So I took that as a sign of like,
wow,
that was really hard for you.
Gail registrar comes back,
no record of him.
Uh,
none of my friends that went to Yale know who he is.
And every time I ask him anything,
like the answer is super simple.
Like if I asked you where you live,
you just tell me to just roll off your tongue.
And that's everything was so I go to that house,
like I let a couple of weeks go by.
My birthday happens.
We had Christmas,
my birthday,
and it's a day before I'm leaving for San Antonio to go to play this comedy
club,
and I go to his house and my friend,
and it's not his house,
it's like some other woman lives.
They're like an old woman lives there.
It's not as mom's house.
And he sees like my mom,
he's like you.
My mom bought the house from me to keep my cash liquid.
The title's not in her name.
I call him and I was like,
I'm walking out of your life because you're lying about something.
And it all came crashing down at 7:00 AM he texts me,
he goes,
I never went to Yale.
I never bought a house.
I've been lying to you for over a year.
And so it was just one of those like,
and then so you start going back and then you start wondering if you're crazy
and then you're like,
does your mom even if cancer did you,
are you really in the small of cancer?
I'm going to say she does,
but I think it's really weird that I met her once and then like I was like,
what's the name of the doctor at the hospital where she is?
He's like,
I don't know,
like very like wouldn't give any information.
This is,
and so yesterday I wrote an email,
I don't know why I'm sharing all of this,
but this is very funny to me.
I wrote everybody,
when you break up with someone,
depending on how tactful you are,
you hold back on what you want to say.
Like we all say,
look,
you're an asshole.
I hate you.
But like then there's like the dark shit that you don't write.
And I wrote an email that I almost,
I won't do it,
but I almost want to post online as like a template for any girl that ever wants
to like enraged her next boyfriend.
And I just lost my shit and it felt so good.
Like fuck.
Having tact.
Like it just was the best thing ever.
Well it sounds like you gave him every possible,
every possible scenario for him to be truthful.
Like you gave him every possible like,
well maybe he's this and maybe it's that you gave a lot of leeway so much so and
then every day I'd be like,
if you're lying,
please just tell me or just tell anyone to look me in the eye and be like,
I'm not lying.
Which makes me think if we ever got married we would go on a boat and he would
kill me.
But the whole never know.
Right.
You never know how that shit happens.
You find out he's got a life insurance policy on you and I and I accidentally
signed it.
Did you find out where he worked?
Did he actually have the job that he had?
He had left the company and all of these things are weird.
Like he left the company and like a weird way and he started his own so that
like I just at some point it's not up to you to piece together what's real and
what isn't.
I told this story on the radio in Tampa and when I got off the air,
all of these people that sent me tweets with Hashtag Yale and somebody sent me a
picture of someone running the Boston marathon in a Yale shirt and they're like,
is your ex boyfriend running the Boston marathon?
Oh the poor bastard.
I'm glad you don't say his name publicly shame him because the poor fuck is
already a mess.
I told him he's fucking lucky.
I'm like you're I think on that show I did but I didn't.
I've never say the last name.
Well he is lucky you could make them a part of your act with his actual name.
It's so little bit.
If I could think of unrelatable the whole like that amount of lying,
like cheating is one thing I thought meant you meant like as a bit right.
I think it's very relatable.
I think I will get around to it.
I think eventually it'll stop.
I'll stop being cause I'm not sad anymore,
but my email pretty much included cause like obviously you know if you break up
with someone don't want to hear about people are sleeping with right.
He got upset because I posted a picture when I was in Saint Martin of Mian
Topless beach with two friends in front of me so he can't see anything.
And he was like,
I felt that you posted that picture and it was directed at me,
which it wasn't like I posted it like a hot picture.
And so I just unleashed on this email and I was like,
it's none of your fucking business.
What I do.
And by the way,
when I was in Saint Martin,
I hooked up with a guy and he went down on me for 20 minutes and it was fucking
awesome.
I will never talk to him.
Whoa,
that's dark.
It felt so good.
Oh that makes you cringe.
But the idea of the act doesn't make me cringe at all.
The writing that email and say,
oh look,
that was a guy and he went down.
He ate my pussy.
I didn't say anything.
Same thing you said it.
Here's the question though.
At what point are you as a human being allowed to just unleash and be like,
that's it.
This,
honestly,
I don't think that guy's worth your effort,
you know,
making more tension with him.
I mean,
that's a crazy person that guys fabricating in existence.
He fabricated as education.
He fabric.
He may have fabricated his mother being sick.
He fabricated where he lived twice or three times.
Three times.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's probably pathological.
You know,
there are people that just can't stop lying.
I've seen it before.
When you're living in Hollywood,
you know,
if you live around here,
you,
you'll meet people that are,
you know,
fake it til you make it type people that will tell you stories that just don't
add up.
And in the old days used to just have to kind of accept people at those stories.
But now your mom can just Google them and find out anything
thing and she got on it.
Wow.
Your mom's awesome.
Good for her.
Well,
let me ask you this,
cause this is,
um,
this is the difference between a man and a woman because you could tell me that
you went to pierce college or you went to a high school and you dropped out when
you're 16,
and if you're,
you and I like you,
I don't care at all.
It doesn't mean anything to me.
I don't care if you a nurse,
I don't care if you're a doctor.
I don't care if you're a brain surgeon or a girl who works in a clothing store.
It doesn't matter to me if I do not care.
I do not care if someone's fun and nice to be around.
I do not care.
I really don't.
I never have.
I never will.
Um,
obviously it's,
it's a,
there's a difference between a man and a woman,
like women desire men to be successful.
Sure.
And that's a whole,
that's an illusion thing.
And that's a protective thing.
And that's,
I get that.
Obviously I don't want a date like a homeless person.
Right.
What killed nor does,
nor do I,
yeah.
I mean,
I don't want someone who can't feed themselves.
Does.
You know what kills me is that those things genuinely don't matter and he chose
to judge me ahead of time,
or maybe he's got a chemical imbalance from the day I met him on the plane.
I went to Yale.
Nothing wrong with lying to a stranger or a pretty girl on a plane.
I don't care where there is something wrong with you,
man.
There's no,
there's no ramifications for lying to a stranger if you never see them again.
Right.
Okay.
That doesn't bother me.
I don't care if you own a house,
so it irks me.
It's a shame because you lied about two things.
Let's say it's just too,
and you ruined a perfectly good relationship.
If it's just those two things in your insecure,
I didn't go to Harvard.
I'm not a road scholar.
I don't care if you went to Yale,
how long did you guys date for?
I knew him for over a year and we dated for about three months.
And what was it about his personality that was attracted to you?
Does a whizzer a unique thing that you could define?
Truthfully,
I mean as friends,
he was very smart.
I,
I really,
for me intelligence is a huge thing and very,
and a little like funniest,
snobby way,
like a little con and I kind of liked that and he's very smart,
very,
very smart,
a little Dorky,
very smart.
But when he,
when we were friends and when he called me and was like,
we can't go on this trip to the skull and bones thing because my mom has cancer.
I got a chance.
This is going to be weird.
I don't know.
I think only women will relate to this for the whole time we knew each other.
He put me on this pedestal,
always asking,
can you please,
can we please date?
Can I have the kids?
Will you be my girlfriend?
And I were like,
we would hang out.
And I was like,
stop it.
Like I'm not into this.
So no one wants to be on a pedestal because there's nothing for you to do.
His mom had cancer.
I was like,
I can take care of you now.
Like you've been nothing but sweet to me.
Now let me take care of you.
And in getting to take care of him,
I started to like him cause I had like an active role.
That's so crazy.
Um Wow.
But yeah,
those things didn't matter.
So is that like the maternal instincts that you have is like the taking care of
instincts,
you know,
because some women have those instincts sort of built in those?
I think so.
But I think it was also just,
there was nothing for me to do to have an active role in our relationship as
friends.
Like he had a lot of money and a lot of time and he could do nice things like he
would,
did he really have a lot of money because you'd have a lot of money.
Well,
how's that possible?
He has a fucking roommate.
So the roommate,
if,
if the answer was he goes,
I have,
my lease was up in Santa Monica.
I was going to buy a house.
But then I decided I thought it was going to move.
He goes again.
Then you and I started dating.
I didn't wanna move.
I moved in with a friend to help her pay her rent cause he's never home and he's
like,
so I just leave my stuff there,
but how can they even trust that I couldn't,
he did send me a picture of his bank account to like why use a human being?
Come on,
I didn't ask for it.
He sent you the numbers in his bag.
Can you send me like a screen grab of it?
This motherfucker doctored his bank.
He might've shot the shit out of his bank account.
I,
you know,
I saw the way he lived in the way he,
I mean I do think the money thing is real.
We did,
maybe it may,
I may or may not have done a background check.
So I definitely know when he came from.
Um,
but the answer your question to the House and the,
the college and like he lied about weird things.
What is that?
That's a weird thing man.
Like that saying you went to Yale,
like the Harvard,
Yale,
Ivy League.
Like that's like,
Ooh,
like,
like I don't,
and then he would sit,
my cousin went to Yale and they would have a conversation and he would talk
about it.
What?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Poor bet you're ripping paper over there.
If you hear that and she's going crazy fucker.
No,
no,
not even that.
Every time we think about it,
I go back and I'm like,
what?
What clues did I miss?
What am I?
And like,
what,
what am I realizing now?
Like I'm trying to like put the dots,
connect the dots.
The day I met him,
I went on Twitter and I followed him and his Twitter handle hadn't had a Yale
reference in it.
And I asked him,
look,
when we broke up,
I was like,
keeping your Twitter was about Yale.
And he was like,
I made up my Twitter account the day I met you.
Whoa.
Just because he met you and he wanted,
oh my God,
good.
He didn't,
maybe he lied.
Maybe change the name.
Uh,
wow.
What a psycho.
And every time I tell the story,
like I think about different things that I've missed.
So Jesus Christ,
the good news is when something that weird happens to you,
there's no lesson to be learned.
It's not like,
oh I thought he was cheating.
Like that's a normal thing.
Like this is not something I'll take into another relationship.
Well you kind of do because you guys do lie about their past to become more
impressive to a girl.
You know?
I mean it is really,
it's super common,
right?
And now you'll sort of recognize those sort of bullshit signs maybe quicker.
Well maybe it's like when a guy throws that out there like makes a big deal out
of it.
Like maybe that's when you look.
Maybe,
maybe.
I mean some people like it wasn't really online.
Some people take pride in not really being online a lot that,
I mean the Internet helps.
Like even if you can,
I went on a date last night and you could Google the guy and everything about
them.
Is there an,
and you're like
me and this guy had no friends in common.
Like the email I wrote him was so I guess so pointed.
We forward it to me.
I'll send it.
I'll show it to you right after this.
I went online and he had deleted his Twitter account.
Like,
I think I made this motherfucker leave cyberspace.
Well you should.
I mean that's for him.
It's gotta be some people just do that over and over and over again though.
I'm my friend Eddie met this guy and this guy,
um,
ah,
he was working on,
he wanted to put him in some project.
He was doing some television project and he claimed that he had these studios
and he was working with all these networks and this and that.
But where we found out that he was full of Shit,
I thought he was full of Shit right away.
I told Eddie,
I like,
I don't like the way Scott talks.
He named jobs too much.
I go,
I think he's a bullshitter.
I think there's a certain thing that people do when they bullshit when they talk
about like,
I've got a project going on with Steven Spielberg and this,
there's just no fucking way Tom Cruise is passing on the project.
We want to bring it to you.
Like,
you know,
you know what I mean?
It's like one of those things.
Sure.
So I,
you know,
I was peripheral,
I wasn't,
you know,
interacting with sky,
but Eddie was interacting.
This guy,
I'm like any of that guy's a bullshitter.
He smells,
I go,
I just,
he just smells.
So,
um,
then the guy starts taking Jujitsu class.
Okay.
I mean zero experience in Jujitsu and then calls Eddie after doing Jujitsu for
like,
I dunno,
like a day,
maybe two days and is talking about catching people and triangles and all these
different submissions that he pulled off,
which is never going to happen.
It's just not going to happen unless,
unless you're doing it with someone who's absolutely physically and competent.
When you,
when you first start out,
you don't know what you're doing,
you don't learn that day one,
we'll also,
he's not a stud.
The guy wasn't like,
there's certain guys like you could tell a guy,
he's like a pro basketball player who's just a fucking athlete and maybe he
loves MMA and maybe he's never taken the Jujitsu classes life.
But he's seen a few fights and if he recognizes the position that you teach it
to him,
he could maybe pull it off on someone who sucks but it's an advanced move like
setting up a triangle,
finishing it.
It's an advanced move and this guy was like,
I got three triangles today and practice and to armbars when we were like,
wait,
what?
And I go,
I told you he's a bullshitter.
And then he go,
well he did actually go to class.
He did not ever tap anyone ever.
He is physically and competent.
Like if you,
if you see him,
you look at his body is like this guy is lucky if he can brush his teeth like
this isn't a fucking athlete at all.
I mean he was just like,
it was a gumby.
He was a guy who essentially had never worked out his whole life and then all of
a sudden he's claiming he's tapping people out in Jujitsu.
But that was just confirmation.
Then ed,
he looked into his,
his whole situation and found out the guy was just a total complete liar and
broke it down with them over the phone.
There's another one I've got,
there's a guy,
he,
his name,
his real name was Ralph and he was telling us that his name was Rafael Tori.
And um,
he was saying that he was a black belt in Jujitsu,
but just as friends or like how did you,
well this guy I'm telling us.
Okay.
He was at his friend and he was a journalist for a mixed martial arts magazine,
an online magazine.
And so he would go to these events and uh,
and he would do,
Eddie was a,
one of the commentators for the king of the cage,
which is a smaller mixed martial arts,
uh,
organization familiar with are,
you know,
and uh,
anyway,
Rafael Tory actually had a fake fight.
I mean he,
he said that he was a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
He was not at all.
Eddie rolled with them.
And Eddie is a black belt.
And at the time,
I don't think Getty was a black,
but I think Eddie was a brown belt and then he just smashed him,
just tapped him left and right.
And he was like confused.
He was like,
well,
maybe they didn't.
Maybe it wasn't really trying.
Like I don't get it because he was a bigger guy too.
It was like way too easy for Eddie to tap them.
So Eddie there,
there was a few like red flags that popped up there.
Anyway,
long story short,
the guy never digits before it was a complete fake would disappear.
And here's a good one.
Went away.
Okay.
Told his friend to drop him off.
Like pulled up to this a wooded area,
told his friend to drop off.
He had a duffle bag with them,
filled with some shit.
Right?
He says,
drop me off here.
I'm going to fight in this,
uh,
no rules.
Karate tournament out in the woods and uh,
I'll be back in two days.
Okay.
So his friend comes back in two days and now he doesn't have the duffle bag
anymore.
Buddy has a trophy that's the same size as the fucking duffle bag.
And he said,
God,
I won this no rules karate tournament.
I mean,
and everybody's like,
wait,
what the fuck?
Okay,
so the guy completely made up is martial arts background completely made up.
He also went to Thailand for a fight and got a guy in a twister.
A twister is a very complex move that involves not just getting on top of Oh
God,
but getting on top of guy inside control,
lacing one leg with your two legs rolling on your shoulders.
So you go behind him,
take his bath,
you wrap his arm around your head,
grab his head and Torque his spine.
It's an incredibly complex maneuver.
This guy had just learned it and he started pulling it off on people in,
in a fucking no holds barred fight.
So there was all these things.
So Eddie,
Eddie cuts the guy off and he's like,
listen man,
you're bullshit artists.
I know you're full of shit.
You're not a fucking black belt.
You're not fighting in these fucking fights.
He's wanting to be near it.
Yeah,
he goes,
I know that your fight.
But Eddie had been friends with this guy for months and months and months and
just slowly piled on the bullshit,
you know,
just not trying to investigate a guy,
just thinking he's a cool guy.
He was already in the mix before Eddie got there.
He was already deepen with these mixed martial arts guy.
So he just assumed that a guy's legit.
Turns out as the time goes on,
he murdered a guy,
murdered a guy who was married to a girl that he was fucking,
he got close to the guy and I guess he had like some sort of karate school that
he was teaching that with his fake fake martial arts and uh,
got the guy to come to his school,
strangled him,
killed him,
and then was driving the guy's car,
Rau witnesses,
saw him drive the guy's car around and um,
had a gun that he gave to my friend Gerald and told Gerald to hide it.
And then Gerald,
you know,
calls me up and tells me the whole situation.
And I was like,
what?
What the fuck happened?
The Guy,
what he kills him.
And then Gerald goes to the cops.
Okay.
And then the cops called me because Gerald had apparently been,
um,
they had wiretapped him while all this was going down because they suspected
that this guy,
Raphael,
his real name was Ralph is,
it wasn't Brazilian.
That's the worst part of the line.
You said he was Brazilian and he wasn't resilient.
It'd be he just faked his ethnicity.
He faked his martial arts background and now he's in jail for life.
I mean,
he's a,
he's in jail for murder in a lot of twisters in jail.
That's what you're saying there.
Is that not,
that's the ultimate bullshit.
Ours fake black belt,
fake ethnicity,
fake name.
Everything is fucking amazing.
It's hilarious.
That story is so crazy.
It makes you sound crazy when you're telling.
Yes it does.
Well,
you can look the guy up.
Google the guy,
Rafael,
Tori.
I mean it's,
uh,
it's an incredible story that gets passed back and forth through the mixed
martial arts world.
But the point is that before the Internet,
I mean this was,
there was websites back then and there was martial arts websites.
It was like 2000 I want to say like two or three or something like that,
but you couldn't like Google the guy you could like find out the guy's
background.
Like if you Google Eliza slouching anger that I sat,
I say,
all right,
there's no sugar in the middle.
[inaudible] hi said No.
How do you say it's it?
Right?
Well,
I've been saying slush,
ginger forever.
Slessinger Schlesinger slashing Sleshinger Schlesinger,
Schlesinger,
I'll never say it wrong again.
Eliza slash
you said it,
you're going to say it wrong every time.
Every time from that one.
It will be wrong.
Just as it's been in the past,
and I'm just going to call you a liar because that's your Twitter handle.
That's who you are to me.
But if I Google you,
I find out about last comic standing,
I see pictures of you topless on the beach with two guys holding their arms over
your titties.
I see a lot of things.
I've seen it.
It's on my message board.
Yeah.
This is Raphael,
Tori,
the guy in the left hand side with the guy on the right hand side with the
glasses is Tito motherfucking Ortiz,
former world champion of the UFC.
So this guy,
this guy,
but this guy got in deep,
that guy on the left,
not the guy without the red in his jacket.
The guy on the detail,
it's his left.
Right.
You know you are right.
This is so complicated.
I'm still is the one,
yeah,
the guy on the right hand side of the photograph.
The guy with the mustache.
Yes.
Thank you.
There we go.
The guy without the glasses.
That's Rafael Torres.
He's in jail for murder and he's a fake black belt and he's uh,
you know everything about his fake,
his names fake.
And that guy like got deep,
deep,
deep in the martial arts world
as a fraud.
That's so crazy.
Fascinating.
Also,
I mean,
I guess you,
and you want to ask Kevin as I asked the ex boyfriend,
I was like,
what was your end game here buddy?
Did you have a conversation with him after this or was it just email and that's
it.
Did you talk,
talk,
he texted and he,
I mean,
he apologize.
This wasn't like Poof,
I'm gone.
Like there's a lot of,
you know.
But did you think about like keeping the Moran couldn't,
couldn't because like you have to take yourself,
I mean,
I even,
I knew this,
you have to take yourself out of like you,
your hurt and your heart's broken.
You're allowed to let that heal.
But getting back with someone like that is not,
first of all,
I lose respect from my all my friends and family.
And then also like,
you can't trust that person.
The end game for you is that you'd be dating someone you couldn't trust.
However.
Um,
but I asked,
you know,
when he just never,
that's the other thing.
And I said in the email,
I was like,
I'm,
I don't have all the answers from him.
I said,
I'm willing to trade my lack of closure for the privilege of never having to
talk to you again.
So I will write my own closure.
I'll draw my own conclusions.
I won't defend you to anyone.
And he went down on me for 20 minutes.
Ah,
yes.
So funny outside is outside too,
Huh?
Danger,
danger,
pussy.
Um,
that's so crazy that did that.
The lack of closure thing is a big thing,
right?
Cause you'll stay up late to try to figure it out.
Do you like find yourself like during the day,
like just driving around trying to piece it together?
Yeah.
Where did it,
I was sitting on the plane yesterday and like you're here,
especially when you just go through a breakup,
like you're,
you know,
you think about that person,
whatever.
And the hard thing is not,
I'm past that phase.
Like there's no,
the blocked,
like I can't call him or anything,
but yeah.
You sit there and you go back over things and then I start like,
here's a weird piece of the puzzle if you want to know what I was thinking.
Um,
when before we were dating,
he invited me to go to England for the skull and bones thing and obviously not
in skull and bones.
You didn't go to Yale.
And even after this all happened,
he goes,
well,
my dad was in skull and bones and I'm like,
your dad went to Yale Grad school,
what's his name?
What's Your Dad's name?
But Dad's dead in real life.
That's what I mean that for.
But uh,
he invited me to go to England,
so I was going to go separate rooms and I went out to dinner with a friend who
has a body that I really liked.
So I took a picture of my drink and in the background was my friend's body.
He's like a big guy.
So the point of the picture was to be like,
look at this hot thing.
I'm having a drink was not so much to me,
like,
look at the drink.
Right.
I think he saw that picture because I don't remember if it was before or after,
but that was the night he called me and said,
we can't go to England.
My mom has cancer.
I think he saw that picture on Instagram and he was like,
I got to do something to shake this up if the mom,
if the mom doesn't have cancer.
It's odd that that was the night of all nights.
So you were friends only up until that point.
Yeah.
Let me tell you something.
There's friends and there's friends with an agenda and you and I are friends.
We will never have sex.
I'll tell you that right now.
I'm married,
we're friends.
I'm not going to let it happen.
Eliza just stop with those eyes.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like we're legitimate friends,
Amy Schumer's and other ones.
She's my legitimate friends and I,
you know,
I think it's very important to like have men and women like that,
that are friends like that.
There's like a line that will never be crossed.
It's like you can't,
but there's guys who are really never your fucking friend.
Never,
ever,
ever.
It's done.
The whole thing was a lie from the beginning.
Like I knew that like I'm not dumb.
And he had said that to me is like goes over your friend but you,
he was someone that I,
we had,
we hung out and we had a really nice like relationship his friends and
definitely I would get drunk once in a while and I'd be like,
let's make out.
Like that's like a girl thing.
But it was never,
oh,
what,
hold on.
You would get drunk and say,
let's make out.
Like I would kiss him and like go inside a big deal.
Well kiss him like tongue and everything,
the whole deal.
Like a drunk,
make out kiss fully clothed and then like go inside.
Whoa.
That's so girl.
It's so crazy.
I also said,
I would say to him,
I'm like,
look at any point,
and I'm very upfront,
honest.
I'd say at any point we can stop hanging out.
I go,
I'm never going to date you.
You need to know that.
And He,
meanwhile you dated him eventually,
but that's not my point is the whole time we were dating,
I was honest.
I was like,
I have no intention of dating you.
Yeah.
But you kissed him tongue.
You can walk away.
I didn't chain him to the wall and I was like,
I'm going to date other guys.
I'm going to have other guys be my boy.
Like not when I was kissing him,
but I was like,
I'm probably never going to date you.
Right.
And he hung around.
Well,
I,
I understand that.
I mean,
well,
he's definitely a silly man for hanging around,
but not because he eventually got to fuck you.
So he wins,
I guess.
I don't think furlough.
Oh,
neat.
Well listen
to you because you're a girl.
Listen,
you kissed him.
You,
you tongued him and he eventually got in there.
But you're telling me that every girl you've brought prior to being married,
ever girl you ever like drunkenly made out with that meant something to you?
No,
no,
but it's,
I think there's a difference between you saying to someone,
look,
first of all,
I'm a man.
When a man drunkenly makes out with a girl,
he absolutely wants a fucker.
If a girl drunkenly makes out with a guy,
she can do it.
Just to be silly,
I guess.
And then just shut the door and go in.
Yeah,
guys don't ever do that.
That's okay.
If a guy drunkenly makes out with a girl,
it's almost always because he eventually ultimately wants to have sex with her.
But,
but um,
but that's what hasn't,
that's how guys are and that's not how girls are.
And I think all any girl would relate to that.
Like,
you know,
or you're just,
I mean you're drunk and you want it.
Sometimes you just want to make out with someone and that's the God's honest
truth.
Like we all get horny and I don't feel like having had those expo.
Here's my point though.
No matter what relationship you're conducting,
even like,
even if you feel I'm throwing mixed signals,
you at any point are allowed to walk away.
And at no point was I like,
I love you.
Please stay.
It was me being like,
I'm going to make out with you.
Maybe I'll take my shirt off.
I'm not going to date you.
Maybe I'll go anyway.
But this one,
the whole time they will,
I started from day one side isn't as if like they came into play later,
like the whole time.
And then I think what he was like,
what happened is I lied and I know what to do.
He's like,
I didn't think we would date.
You always told us,
told me we wouldn't.
And then we did.
He's like,
I didn't know what to do.
And I'm like,
hold on,
it's on you.
Well that's definitely on him and the lies are unacceptable.
I just,
all I'm trying to do is as your friend breakdown though the mindset and try to
figure out like how someone says,
I'll tongue you and kiss you and take my shirt off,
but we're never going to have sex for a guy that's like,
if we're getting that close,
if your tits are coming out and my tongue's in your mouth.
Okay.
I was joking about the shirt thing.
Uh,
I don't think,
I think everybody's been there words for like a drunk make out to the end of the
night and you're just like,
whatever.
I feel like making out.
And so you do like you like I know this person and this is fine and they're like
I ever totally support your,
your right to make out with people and you're drunk and have like a very
specific boundary where it's not going to go any further than this.
We're never going to date,
but if you want to make out,
I'll make out with you right now.
But that's it.
And then that's it.
That's your,
your your prerogative.
100% is on your show.
We did,
I mean like a long time ago where I will,
if I'm like,
let's say I'm seeing someone and let's say it's like the second date or
something,
I will straight up say to a guy,
I'm not going to sleep with you just yet.
Like I don't,
I'm not going to do that.
But if you wanna go upstairs,
we can make out among touch your wiener,
I'll take my shirt off.
That is a treat for you
tomorrow you'll buy me breakfast and no one has ever said no.
When you give men certain boundaries or parameters ahead of time,
right.
They,
and then I'm giving you the option to say I'm good,
or I'm tired,
or I think I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go home.
Whatever you want.
That way you're not disappointed.
No one's ever pushed it.
No one's ever tried to get me to do more than wanting to do.
And one's ever said no.
Well,
you're a very strong personality,
you know?
And if you say that a guys,
I'm not saying every guy would respect it,
but most guys who go,
she's not fucking around like this is what she wants.
And it's better than nothing for a lot of guys that like,
well yeah,
it's better than nothing.
Yeah,
I'll go make out and squeeze some titties.
And we like date.
Yeah,
yeah.
And then eventually we'll fuck.
So it's like,
yeah,
well there's nothing wrong with that because also we're talking to,
if I was a girl also it would be really difficult for me,
I assume,
to just trust a man.
Like physically,
like there's the physical thing like,
look,
you had this guy,
you knew him for a fucking year,
you data for three months and he turned out to be a complete total bull sharks.
What if it was,
you knew him for a year,
you dated him for three months and he turn out to be a fucking psychopath and
you didn't know the whole time you were dating.
Well sort of,
but what if it's the whole time you were dating?
He was raping girls while you weren't around?
I mean that's just as possible as him faking Yale.
He could have been a serial rapist or with a gun.
Like he could be a total fucking,
yeah.
Did he have a key?
I don't at any point in time,
but he did like from the only thing that,
because we'd known each other for a year.
So when you know someone for a year and then date,
it's a little,
you could take it a little bit faster because it isn't like you just started
dating I've nowhere but like a month.
And he was like,
I'd love to move in.
Like,
what can we move in together?
I've definitely dated guys that liked to go fast and you got to like pump the
brakes and now
you're the guy alive.
I always,
I'm out because I'm like,
yeah,
let's be fucking intense.
Let's,
let's sit in Nancy this into the ground.
Yeah.
But if you really enjoy life and you really enjoy the person fucking why not?
Who gives a shit for this one in particular?
I was like relaxed with the,
with the moving in thing.
Right.
And now and now it's even weird.
I'm like,
so what,
so what was your plan like?
You were going to reveal all this then you'd be living with me.
God,
could you imagine if you were living with this fucking guy and all that stuff
came out?
Uh,
it would have been,
I mean I would have had to take my mortgage from afar.
Yeah.
What would you do?
Jesus Christ physical thing.
I always kind of like test.
If I'm dating someone,
like I'll be like,
let's,
I'm going to try to get past you and see if you can stop me.
Are you serious?
I was just trying to see like physically where we are.
I definitely almost beat a boyfriend in a wrestling,
an arm wrestling match one time.
Yeah.
Not everybody works out and not everybody's angry,
but I definitely was saying I work out in them angry.
So we were trying to say I did not implies and comparative.
Uh,
but the physical thing I definitely,
but it really works on that.
Everybody's angry.
That's not what I meant for me.
I know I'm saying,
I mean I was paying,
I'm,
I work out and I'm angry.
You just,
you just gotta Know How to sling it.
You know,
bullshit.
It does work on occasionally,
even with smart.
I mean that's what's the most impressive thing about his accomplishment.
You are,
you know,
you're one of my smartest friends.
You're smart.
You're very smart.
You're very quick.
And for a god,
a tricky like that and a trick you over a long period of time with a lot of,
you know,
a lot of questions along the where you hit some bumps
I guess.
But here's the other thing.
I mean,
I,
I don't even know if the word is trick and I'll,
I mean,
I totally fell for it.
The shit out of you.
I feel like,
I guess it is tricky,
but it's also the ones he's like,
why would I question that in my life?
No one's ever lied about where they went to school that I knew of.
Right.
These are not lies that in society we're told to look out for.
It'd be one like everyone's like,
does he have another family?
I would even think about like your school,
like who cares?
It's like lying about your blood type.
Well,
not just his,
he lied about where most likely,
let's be honest,
most likely a about his mom having cancer because you were dating a big heart
guy,
you know,
and he most likely lied.
Well,
he definitely lied about the skeleton bones part about England.
He lied about his house twice.
He lied about,
you know,
he sounds like a guy who just lies at a d.
It means probably gotten laid doing that his whole life.
I don't think he's gotten late enough.
I think that's what it was.
And I'm just thinking about it.
No,
because I don't think it's,
he's not like,
I'll look,
I totally got tricked.
I'm not above admitting that.
I'm also not above admitting that.
I think when you love someone,
you're judgment is clouded.
And I didn't,
I didn't know the scope of what that could be.
I didn't in a billion years,
I wouldn't have thought that that was real.
Like I thought it was a joke that like,
oh,
we can't find is the diploma,
whatever,
but you won't.
You almost don't want it to be true.
Okay.